what's the craziest experience you've  had with the fan since you've become  part of Star Wars well I met this lovely  woman at the airport and she started to  cry and said are you sir it's only the  beginning which characters from the old  series that returned to remote excited  to write they were all really fun to  write I would say that probably han was  the most fun what is your earliest Star  Wars memory was being off a school in  Kenya and curling up on a poof in my in  our living room watching the movie and  now look at this tonight it's like it's  otherworldly there's something pretty  cool watching stars connect with their  fans like that I love it now our friends  at Microsoft wanted us to remind you to  upgrade your PC's and your surface  tablets to Windows 10 if you haven't  done so already they say it's faster  they say it's more secure with lots of  new features like Cortana your own  digital personal assistant